a career in travel came to a painful
halt last year for Hillary a fall left
the tour guide and events organizer from
bath with a shattered hip and pelvis a
diagnosis of osteoporosis and a long
road back to work I work in event
management and it is quite a physical
job you're expected to stand for for
long lengths of time
I can move around but I'm not able to
run
I can cycle
but
there are many more trip hazards that I
have to be aware of now it seemed like a
very long tunnel that I was going to
have to get through and really it I
would say it's taken a year I've had
some dark moments I would definitely
like to be working again and I still
hope to be working again I've worked at
eight Olympic Games I'd really like to
work at the Paris Olympics Hillary is
one of a record number of people unable
to work because of long-term illness a
trend that's grown since the pandemic
and helped Drive unemployment to a
48-year low 9 million people are
classified as economically inactive
that's almost 22 percent of the working
age population
of these almost two and a half million
are long-term sick and among those over
50 18 are on NHS waiting lists for
treatment that have soared since covid
that makes the link between public
health and economic health critical if
you want to grow the economy it relies
on your workers and if you've got
workers who can't work at full capacity
or any capacity because of ill health
you can start to see how the state of
the NHS starts to become a factor
limiting your rate of economic growth
and politicians often say when they talk
about Health and Care funding that a
strong NHS requires a strong economy
what the reverse is true as well
[Music]
the workforce there are still fewer
people employed than before the pandemic
long-term sickness is one of the reasons
there are more unfilled jobs in the
economy more than 1.2 million than there
are unemployed people to do them it is a
stubborn reality made Harder by the
barriers of brexit and it tells us the
labor market is struggling to meet
current demand let alone the growth the
new government says it wants
competition for workers means wages are
rising but not as fast as inflation so
real terms earnings are falling down
four percent another headache for
workers and an ailing economy Paul Kelso
Sky News in bath